we just saw digital media implode over
the past few weeks and it's been in
freef Fall for the past couple years one
of the worst days ever they got a call
it like bloody Thursday or something how
many layoffs there were this week yeah
Taylor Loren's video of her complaining
about all of it I mean they're laying
people off during election season you
know election writers as well which is
insane but I have a problem with you
know people not attending like I
understand protests I understand the
point of them obviously they're not
hyper effective especially after January
6th but everybody has essentially been
neutered after January 6 and I was there
on January 6 so I understand the ramif
I'm not saying don't protest don't
organize don't get together don't have
assemblies I'm saying don't go up
against CBP on federal jurisdiction
during a conflict like especially when
border patrol has essentially sided with
the National Guard in this situation I
think the protest was planned before the
Shelby Park stuff happened but now that
this is actually going on it does lead
to potential problems or conflict and I
don't care